so what is happening in that video and
how do I be a part of it you look so
relaxed no I was having an out of Body
Experience ironically while she was
having very much an inside my body
experience it's called it's a type of
face with you guys you gotta try it it's
a type of face massage that I saw
scrolling on Instagram and I was like I
have TMJ so this would be me yeah it's
first time you're gonna love this yeah
it's called well she goes all over your
face it's called the um buccal facial
buccal buccal I don't know how to
pronounce it all I know is that it
starts with like a lot of face rubbing a
little bit of neck rubbing and then they
put on gloves snap snap inside your
mouth and they're going like oh like
they're like here
and it's wild and I think maybe because
I talk so much WoW a lot of tension a
lot of nerve endings and I feel like
well maybe hot Kettle um yeah it's red
here I am talkative as well and also
singing like I sing all the time and
it's like people don't realize like how
you clinch sometimes she specifically
said you know if you ever sing and I was
like actually sometimes I do and yeah
it's incredible I am so excited about
this I saw this video and I was like
what's what's happening yeah I love any
kind of massage or anything it's like a
holistic I think it's like maybe
originated in Eastern Europe but it's
it's all good things get right up in
there yeah
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]